[Music]
- gone on YouTube so today is a very
spirited development I can't speak
English today is a very very special
bond because we are doing two of my or
not my family for two of my girlfriend's
favorite favorite dishes and you know I
can't have two of her favorite dishes
without her ugly face in here come on
down don't cut my hair
so are these two dishes - favorite
digits why are they named Owen can I say
what they are
yes yes treat your teeth buddy
ah I grew up eating Nina and fried
chicken now in Korea I don't understand
yeah ah
Google Nanyang and fried chicken when I
was growing up how are y'all yay okay
that's how exaggerated like you fell
away
just bring the first dish here first up
we have hops coming tones this is Korean
fried chicken now I know a lot of people
out there specifically my brothers and
sisters my black book outside like that
pretty people don't know fried chicken
what you don't know is that Korean
people love fried chicken and beer that
is like one of our biggest like staple
bar foods I want to say that could
people might do Fried Chicken better
than American people hey I'm famous
so let's go ahead and bite into this
delicious dish right here
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
okay however shiz that's good
oh my God look I've got a problem myself
right now
what's the first time I ever made I
never made this before and the recipe
that I used was put on somebody else
online and I didn't like your
proportions I take this often takes my
tune so I kind of just did it myself
my laptop tell them how good it is what
you're feeling about it
it's now perfectly crispy it's hot let's
talk about professor Korean fried
chicken ice cream fried chicken
typically that you see like in on
American or Southern Fried Chicken
you'll see people do it with the batter
cream pie chicken is a little bit
different it's all about that crispy
crunchy texture you want to last for a
very long time so we have to don't use
the batter but we use is potato starch
now potato starch is interesting now a
lot of people too when they try to
replace the potato sides with listing
cornstarch cornstarch is not gonna work
as well then the reason why is because
construction have any protein in it and
you need that protein to get that brown
crispy crunchiness and that's how you
get this is practically shells and when
you bite into it it's a quick like kinds
it's so good
so Park I'm done is actually made with a
soy sauce rice wine vinegar sugar
and where I do likely add a little
softball until it got a little pit we're
not to make it too spicy
and how do we actually use oh my god
when you mix it with your life hey my
older brother by the way will wear it
again
[Music]
well no I'm gonna let you saw any kind
of took over my place in the reason why
I'm going back and forth from doing this
is because I don't want to make this
ahead of time because I don't like soggy
fried chicken I like it fresh I like it
now and when it kind of goes past that
30-minute marking it's really just kind
of like chewy and weird but let's talk
about the thing I added on the second
round right here which is this this is a
rest move and what you do with this this
is a lot of clean restaurants you kind
of into like a refreshing by after you
leave something so savory and heavy it
basically you pickle it and sugar
vinegar that's it sugar and ice cream
and some salt and that's really what you
have here so you'll take your chicken
so Muriel earlier was giving me crap
about the the chicken because of the way
that I was eating but I'll be leaving
the queue for later then why does the
flight you every time I want it my arm
so to watch my parents is like chicken
wings and they would eat it and when
they're done it would look like an
archeological find right here with a
fossil but there was no remanent of meat
on it whatsoever there was no car
location not me like that and the reason
why I found I hated it with because I
don't like that should we caught a lot
English stuff but if you fry it long
enough when you double fry it s that
becomes crunchy and that fries not get
the sauce and it's just a delicious
treat your hands right there
yes really yeah it's like a little a
chicken trip so everybody out there that
doesn't need a chicken wing like this
you're wasting food you're wasting all
the good stuff give it to an Asian
person
No
you know I think I mean I thought about
this little bus it no no no we're gonna
talk about this so when Mary on I first
started going now what she did so I went
over to her place and she says she
thought that she was gonna make me
dinner
let me ask you guys is what does make
you dinner what does make you dinner
mean can I talk about what I talk about
it makes you get it usually means that
you're creating something no you're not
on a mother hen we're talking about
making you food now at this point to
Iowa I've already made allies that
delicious nonsense dinner so I assume
video she was gonna you know make me
something decent and I mind you I don't
care what you make me I'm very grateful
this is what happened she didn't make
you dinner
so she just had a whole bunch of
store-bought korean foundation she puts
it into a bowl and she brings me right
what is fun but I'm really ok with that
so it turns out that the right there she
made wasn't that good so as I was eating
the food I said hey you know what pretty
cool
okay at this she start hounding me about
oh you never that fool really so what
was wrong
like I'm you that he wasn't for yeah I
didn't want to run matter wait food and
for the first time - Marysol you wasting
food so I'm like what the hell what
happened what you say I'll never forget
that moment it's been two years since
then let it go she hasn't made me a
single meal a production I'm now in the
beginning of our relationship
oh my heart it was it's just right
yeah it's so great but you make good
food nice a lista like you to meet you
food really in my heart feel the best
part of chicken wings are looking at
Theatre Center I can't stop even more
[Music]
thing is beginning of our relationship
you would think that he'd be nice enough
not to say that in front of his
girlfriend and no handle come along okay
so that is right girl
right all about the effort line water
who knows how to cook right
[Music]
let me pretty good reaction
[Music]
[Music]
get a [ __ ] what you say go ahead to
hear you is delicious and I make great
reaction I look like this song I told
you the reason why I said your wife is
done what's good in my honest person
you got something bad about me if you
record I'm mostly the footage later
oh okay cuz I learn it I'm on it no I'm
honest motile is good life mmm-hmm like
that husband that's a tree like this oh
my god I beat the crap he is such a liar
he is being very and if you lie about
something like that then between lying
about other things to me and get it no
I'd rather be honest about it and the
next time you commit your rice better
next time yo ever since then have you
made that right no you have a good no
good righteous oh my just gonna be that
garbage
and how I feel about you make good food
as I eat it and I'm in fact let me eat
it you don't make bad food you just make
bad rice one time one time really bright
for visit maybe get one heart here but
I'm never proud and like a lot of things
that I do but when it comes to food
I'm pretty fun you're good that's all
you laughing it
you just ate by 17 wins having this
right here probably goes up with some of
the best yeah you're right so that's the
problem
what the hell you're talking about it
okay I feel like I should affect that
you say your own somebody made this like
pretty one was that's one for the book I
know and it's fascinating to actually
say this because we're going to go back
to a people pulling you right now never
is that's good
what she Bennett who she goes haha and I
go whatever I make good reaction next up
is one of Mario's favorite summer dishes
this right here is called Megan young
now named gun is interesting for those
of you guys who've never had like a cold
dish before the cold noodle dish it
might be a little bit weird so the
noodles are going to be an arrowroot
noodle it's really really chewy I
actually like that texture a lot enough
kind of like marital matter likes it too
we have a soft-boiled egg on top and
everything I made here from scratch from
the soup which is called the YouTube
I made from scratch as well with the
beef brisket that you see right here at
the end the more i marinate or i pickled
it myself and this right here is three
delicious pieces of ribeye you know like
I said why not
usually get this like overly cooked
piece of beef which isn't bad
it was kind of like reminiscent of what
I had as a kid but I just amp it up and
just give ourselves a little bit about
BB cream
don't forget young got that oh yeah so
they put in um Chinese hot mustard in
this trainee it was Chinese so it gives
it a little bit of a kick some people do
it with wasabi we just simplify before
with the hot mustard
yeah what do they just do good
what's different right the discretion
both on the packet when she's a lot
different it's all that was more bland
yeah
yeah I look kick to it
mmm so the the flavor I could really get
from the soup is going to be sweet and
hanging and that's what you're gonna get
salt leave this put the piece of rib eye
hold on by the way my Asian eat noodles
and soup we've make noises oh that's
right and it's perfectly okay no that's
funny um people say that a big one or
will even get a few people in general
like if you select your food like people
say that you're the Savage it's like
really improper etiquette by like for
Asian people when you slip your new list
shows like respect because you're saying
you can really really enjoin the food
yeah because without it like it's like
it's like this yeah this is like one of
the ultimate summer dishes is originally
from North Korea well that's right this
is the most mean to humans all right no
kidding I know this is a North Korean
dish this one is but then they don't put
ice it's actually like a bookworm hmm
and they secrete and in the drop is a
lot more point your charge in Korea is
at the traditional North Korean name
yeah it is not close I like the sauce
Korean style where you put eyes and
makes it a little more spicy and pink if
you ask me if I can what I mean I'm
getting going again
mmm probably not he'll our way for my
Colina subscribed in a lot of work
because even a nerd enough in the pack
opening the new such criminals they'll
give you like a try packet of YouTube
yeah
so you can make it yourself but the mole
tastes like this if you mean maybe a
purse crashes way different I got
amazing
I asked you that I really wanted a would
you make it for me
you will probably have a period of time
when you're pregnant no that's good
that's right that's a hard time for me
like I can't say no he's pregnant the
baby ones would have one baby one name
is did you have Brenda but you are
giving that's also screaming oh I can't
have another bite what do is interesting
guys like if you guys cook food and
people are like all and you should do
this and that to it well you know yeah
basically go pups go [ __ ] yourself
because you're not the one guys eating
it when I eat it it's going to come out
of poop out of my [ __ ] not yours so
really it's just kind of like cook it to
your own taste if you're the only one
that's going to eat the food and you
enjoyed if you liked it then just eat it
like those don't worry about you know
being so strict to like authenticity
authenticity is [ __ ] what people say
like this is the only way you can make
something well if you go to everybody
else's house in a certain country or
region everybody could make that
authentic dishes different way so make
it to your taste if you like it and you
enjoy that all that matters but your
house is terrible
I'm sorry mom why hey what are going on
YouTube now today's video is going to be
interesting because there aren't going
to be too many giggles but I'm going to
be talking about something pretty
serious now topically speaking today I'm
going to be talking to you about